today I stand before you as a man who
lives life to the full in the here and
now but for a long time I lived for
death I was a young man who believed
that jihad is to be understood in the
language of force and violence I tried
to right wrongs through power and
aggression
I had deep concerns for the suffering of
others and a strong desire to help and
bring relief to them I thought violent
jihad was noble chivalrous and the best
way to help at a time when so many of
our people young people specially are at
risk of radicalization through groups
like al-qaida Islamic State and others
when these groups are claiming that
their horrific brutality and violence
are true jihad I want to say that their
idea of jihad is wrong completely wrong
as was mine then jihad means to strive
to one's utmost it includes exertion in
spirituality self purification and
devotion it refers to positive
transformation through learning wisdom
and remembrance of God the word jihad
stands for all those meanings as a whole
jihad may at times take the form of
fighting but only sometimes under strict
conditions within rules and limits in
Islam the benefit of an act must
outweigh the harm or hardship it entails
more importantly the verses in the Quran
that are connected to jihad or fighting
do not cancel out the verses that talk
about forgiveness benevolence
or patience but now I believe that there
are no circumstances on earth where
violent jihad is permissible because it
will lead to greater harm but now the
idea of jihad has been hijacked it has
been perverted to mean violent struggle
wherever Muslims are undergoing
difficulties and turned into terrorism
by fascistic Islamists like Al Qaeda
Islamic state and others but I have come
to understand that true jihad means
striving to the utmost to strengthen and
live those qualities which God loves
honesty trustworthiness compassion
benevolence reliability respect
truthfulness human values that so many
of us share I was born in Bangladesh but
grew up mostly in England and I went to
school here
my father was an academic and we were in
the UK through his work in 1971 we were
in Bangladesh when everything changed
the war of independence impacted upon us
terribly pitting family against family
neighbor against neighbor and at the age
of 12 I experienced war destitution in
my family the deaths of 22 of my
relatives in horrible ways as well as
the murder of my elder brother
I witnessed killing animals feeding on
corpses in the streets starvation all
around me wanton horrific violence
senseless violence I was a young man
teenager fascinated by ideas I wanted to
learn but I could not go to school for
four years after the war of independence
my father was put in prison for two and
a half years and I used to visit him
every week in prison and home
fooled myself my father was released in
1973 and he fled to England as a refugee
and we soon followed him I was 17 so
these experiences gave me a sharp
awareness of the atrocities and
injustice in the world and I had a
strong desire a very keen deep desire to
right wrongs and help the victims of
oppression while studying at college in
the UK I met others who showed me how I
could channel that desire and help
through my religion and I was
radicalized enough to consider violence
correct even virtue under certain
circumstances so I became involved in
the jihad in Afghanistan I wanted to
protect the Muslim Afghan population
against the Soviet army and I thought
that that was jihad my sacred duty which
would be rewarded by God I became a
preacher I was one of the pioneers of
violent jihad in the UK I recruited I
raised funds I trained I confused true
jihad with his perversion as presented
by the fascist Islamists these people
who use the idea of jihad to justify
their lust for power Authority and
control on earth a perversion
perpetuated today by fascist Islamist
groups like al-qaeda Islamic state and
others for a period of around 15 years I
sure I fought I fought for short periods
of time in Kashmir and Burma
besides Afghanistan our aim was to
remove the invaders to bring relief to
the oppressed victims and of course to
establish an Islamic state
a caliphate for God's rule and I did
this openly I was a didn't break any
laws I was proud and grateful to be
British I still AM and I bore no
hostility against this my country nor
enmity towards the non-muslim citizens
and I still don't
during one battle in Afghanistan some
British men and I formed a special bond
with a 15 year old of Ghani boy
Abdullah an innocent loving and lovable
kid who was always eager to please he
was poor and boys like him did menial
tasks in the camp and he seemed happy
enough but I couldn't help wonder his
parents must have missed him dearly and
they must have dreamt about a better
future for him a victim of circumstance
caught up in a war cruelly thrust upon
him by the cruel circumstances of the
time one day I picked up this unexploded
mortar shell in a trench and I had it
deposited in a mock maid shift makeshift
mud hut lab and I went out on a short
pointless skirmish always pointless and
I came back a few hours later to
discover he was dead he tried to recover
explosives from that shell it exploded
and he died a violent death blown to
bits by the very same device that had
proved harmless to me so I started to
question how did his death how did his
death serve any purpose why did he die
and I lived I carried on I fought in
Kashmir I also recruited for the
Philippines Bosnia and Chechnya and the
questions grew late
in Burma I came across the row hangar
fighters who were barely teenagers born
and brought up in the jungle carrying
machine guns and grenade launchers I met
two 13-year olds with soft manners and
gentle voice looking at me they begged
me to take them away
to England they simply wanted to go to
school that was their dream my family my
children of the same age were living at
home in the UK going to school living a
safe life and I couldn't help wonder how
much these young boys must have spoken
to one another about their dreams for
such a life victims of circumstances
these two young boys sleeping rough on
the ground looking up at the stars
cynically exploited by their leaders for
their personal lust for glory and power
I soon witnessed boys like them killing
one another in conflicts between rival
groups and it was the same everywhere
afghanistan kashmir burma
philippines chechnya petty warlords got
the young and vulnerable to kill one
another in the name of jihad muslims
against muslims not protecting anyone
against invaders are occupiers not
bringing relief to the oppressed
children being used cynically exploited
people dying in conflicts which I was
supporting in the name of jihad and it
still carries on today
realizing that the violent jihad had
engaged in abroad was so different such
a chasm between what I had experienced
and what I thought was sacred duty
I had to reflect on my activities here
in the UK I had to consider my preaching
recruiting fundraising training but most
importantly radicalizing sending young
people to fight and die as I was doing
all totally wrong so I got involved in
violent jihad in the mid 80s starting
with Afghanistan and by the time I
finished it was in the year 2000 I was
completely immersed in it all around me
people supported applauded even
celebrated what we were doing in their
name but by the time I learned to get
out completely disillusioned in the year
2000 15 years had passed so what goes
wrong we were so busy talking about
virtue and we were blind we were blinded
by a cause and we did not give ourselves
a chance to develop a virtuous character
we told ourselves we were fighting for
the oppressed but these were unwinnable
Wars we became the very instrument
through which more deaths occurred
complicit in causing further misery to
the selfish benefit of the cruel few
so overtime a very long time I open my
eyes I began to dare to face the truth
to think to face the hard questions I
got in touch with my soul what have I
learned that people who engage in
violent jihadism
that people who are drawn to these types
of extremism are not that different to
everyone else but I believe such people
can change they can regain their hearts
and restore them by filling them with
human values that heal when we ignore
the realities we discover that we accept
what we are told without critical
reflection and we ignore the gifts and
advantages that many of us would cherish
even for a single moment in their lives
I engage in actions I thought were
correct but now I began to question how
I knew what I knew I end ously told
others to accept the truth but I failed
to give dealt out its rightful place
this conviction that people can change
is rooted in my experience my own
journey through wide reading reflecting
contemplation self-knowledge
I discovered I realized that the
islamists world of us and them is false
and unjust
through considering the uncertainties in
all that we had asserted to be
inviolable truths incontestable truths I
developed a more nuanced understanding I
realized that in a world crowded with
variation and contradiction foolish
preaches only foolish preachers like I
used to be see no paradox in the myths
and fictions they use to assert
authenticity so I understood the vital
importance of self-knowledge political
awareness and the necessity for a deep
and wide understanding of our
commitments and our actions how they
affect others so my plea today to
everyone especially those who sincerely
believed in Islamist jihadism refused
dogmatic Authority let go of anger
hatred and violence learn to right
wrongs without even attempting to
justify cruel unjust and futile behavior
instead create a few beautiful and
useful things that outlive us approach
the world life with love in or learn to
develop or cultivate your hearts to see
goodness beauty and truth in others and
in the world that way we do matter more
to ourselves to each other to our
communities and for me to God
this is jihad my true jihad thank